[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart bran from the
long now foundation welcome I want to
see it work to about our speaker's book
something I've come to admire and even
require and stuff that I'm gonna spend a
whole bunch of time reading or even
listening to is density I want a lot of
insight a lot of news a lot of meat per
paragraph in a book and that's
relatively uncommon but this is about a
third of the way through enlightenment
now you can see I've dog you're just
about every page and that's because the
density of insight and originality and
serious news is that thick in this book
and what will here tonight is not the
book the book has a whole lot more than
what Steve can say in the course of an
hour and a half our conversation so let
me introduce the speaker to the
introduction to enlightenment now Steven
Pinker
thank you so much what an honor it is to
be speaking at the long now and to be
introduced by Stuart brand from time to
time we all ask some deep and difficult
questions why is the world filled with
woe how can we make it better how do we
give meaning and purpose to our lives
well as important as these questions may
seem there are some people with
confident answers to them for example
morality is dictated by God in holy
scriptures when everybody obeys his loss
the world will be perfect for example
problems are the fault of evil people
who must be shamed punished and defeated
our tribe should claim its rightful
greatness under the control of a strong
leader who embodies its authentic virtue
in the past we lived in a state of order
and harmony until alien forces brought
on decadence and degeneration we must
restore the society to its golden age
well what about the rest of us many
people know what they don't believe in
but what what do we believe in in
enlightenment now I suggest that there
is an alternative system of beliefs and
values the one that we associate with
the 18th century enlightenment in a
nutshell that we can use knowledge to
enhance human flourishing many people
embrace the ideals of the Enlightenment
without being able to name or describe
them as a result they faded into the
background as a bland status quo or the
establishment other ideology our
ideologies have passionate advocates and
I suggest that enlightenment ideals to
need a positive defense and an explicit
commitment and that's what I've tried to
do in enlightenment now enlightenment
ideals I suggest revolve around four
themes reason science humanism and
progress let me say a few words about
each it all begins with reason and with
the understanding that traditional
sources of belief are generators of do
faith revelation tradition Authority
charisma mysticism intuition the parsing
of sacred texts are all ways of being
wrong reason in contrast is
non-negotiable
as soon as you try to provide reasons
why we should trust anything other than
reason as soon as you insist that you
are right that other people should
believe you
that you're not lying or full of crap
you've lost the argument because you
have appealed to reason human beings on
their own are not particularly
reasonable cognitive scientists have
shown that we are liable to generalize
from anecdotes to reason from
stereotypes we seek evidence that
confirms our beliefs and we ignore
evidence that disconfirms them and we're
overconfident about our knowledge our
wisdom and our rectitude but people are
capable of reason if they adopt certain
norms free speech open criticism and
debate logical analysis fact-checking
and empirical testing which brings me to
the second enlightenment ideal science
science is based on the conviction that
the world is intelligible and that we
can understand it by formulating
possible explanations and testing them
against reality science has shown itself
to be our most reliable means of
understanding the world including
ourselves an important enlightenment
theme was that there can be a science of
human nature and that beliefs about
society are testable just like any other
beliefs about the world science moreover
provides not just technical know-how but
fundamental insights about the human
condition naturalism the laws of the
universe have no goal or purpose related
to human welfare which means that if we
want to improve that welfare we have to
figure out how to do it ourselves
entropy in a closed system without input
of energy disorder increases things fall
apart stuff happens and that's because
there are vastly more ways for things to
go wrong than to go right evolution
humans are products of a competitor
process which selects for reproductive
success not for wellbeing as a manual
can't put it out of The Crooked Timber
of humanity no truly straight thing can
be built the third enlightenment value
is humanism that the ultimate moral
purpose is to reduce the suffering and
enhance the flourishing of human beings
and other sentient creatures well human
flourishing who could be against that
well in fact there are alternatives to
humanism it is by no means a trite or
banal moral commitment for example there
among the alternatives are that the
ultimate good is to enhance the glory of
the tribe the nation the race the class
or the faith to obey the dictates of a
divinity and pressure others to do the
same to achieve feats of our artistic or
Marcille or heroic greatness to advance
a mystical force a dialectic or struggle
or pursuit of a utopian or messianic age
humanism is feasible because people are
endowed with a sense of sympathy an
ability to show concern for the welfare
of others another recurring
enlightenment theme now by default our
circle of sympathy is rather small we
tend to feel the pain only of our
genetic relatives our friends our allies
cute little furry baby animals and
that's about it
but our our circle of sympathy can be
expanded through forces of
cosmopolitanism the mixing of ideas and
people such as education journalism
mobility art and reason as soon as I
enter into a conversation with you I
can't insist that my interests are
special just because I me and and you're
not and hope for you to take me
seriously
finally this leads to the enlightenment
ideal of progress that if we apply
knowledge and sympathy to reduce
suffering and enhance flourishing we can
gradually succeed well you may ask if
human nature doesn't change how could
progress even be possible and an answer
from the Enlightenment is through benign
institutions that allow us to deploy
energy and knowledge to combat entropy
that magnify the better angels of our
nature
like reason and sympathy while
marginalizing our inner demons our
biases our illusions our tribalism our
thirst for dominance and vengeance
examples of institutions that were brain
children of the Enlightenment that we
continued to enjoy our democracy
declarations of rights markets
organizations for global cooperation and
institutions of truth seeking academies
scientific societies Free Press lecture
series and others so 250 years later how
did that Lightman thing work out well if
you ask most intellectuals the answer is
not very well because I have found that
intellectuals hate progress and
intellectuals who call themselves
progressive really hate progress it's
it's not that they hate the fruits of
progress mind you most members of the
Clara Sea would still rather have their
surgery with anesthesia rather than
without it it's the idea of progress
that rankles the chattering class if you
think we can solve problems I have been
told that means you have a blind faith
and a quasi religious belief in the
outmoded superstition of the false
promise of the myth of the onward march
of inevitable progress you are a
cheerleader for vulgar American can-do
ISM with the rah-rah spirit of boardroom
ideology Silicon Valley and the Chamber
of Commerce you are a practitioner of
Whig history a naive optimist a
Pollyanna
and of course a Pangloss alluding to the
Voltaire character who declared all is
for the best in the best of all possible
worlds well Pangloss as it turns out was
a pessimist true optimist believes there
can be much better worlds than the ones
we have today but this is all irrelevant
because the question of whether there
has been progress is not a matter of
seeing the world through rose-colored
glasses or having
sunny disposition or seeing the glass as
half-full it's an empirical hypothesis
human well-being can be measured life
health sustenance prosperity peace
freedom safety knowledge leisure if they
have increased over time
I submit that is progress so let's look
at the data beginning with life the most
precious resource of all for most of
human history
life expectancy at birth hovered around
30 years of age but then with the
discovery of vaccination sanitation
antibiotics and other advances in public
health and medicine life expectancy
across the world has increased so that
today it is 71 years and virtually no
one guesses that it's that high as with
many examples of human progress the
development has been highly uneven
across the regions of the world Europe
was the first region to escape early
death followed by the Americas in the
20th century Asia has shown spectacular
increases and most recently Africa has
began begun to close the gap the life
expectancy in Europe is greater than 80
years but in all regions of the world
life expectancy at birth is increasing
indeed in Kenya life expectancy and has
increased by 10 years in the last 10
years which means that a for a Kenyan
citizen every year he would get a year
older but not approach death at all
ah child mortality in for most of human
history the greatest reducer of life
expectancy was death in fragile children
even in Sweden which we today we think
of as the the world's most one of the
world's most advanced countries in 1750
one-third of Swedish children did not
make it to their fifth birthday that was
reduced to a third of a percentage point
that is a hundredfold decrease again
other regions of the world got a later
start but followed the same trajectory
here we have Canada in North America
South Korea in Asia Chile hit Latin
America and Ethiopia in sub-saharan
Africa which has reduced its rate of
child mortality from 25 percent to 6
percent still too high but the progress
is continuing in the 18th century 1% of
Swedish women Dyle died in childbirth
that has been brought down by a factor
of two hundred and fifty two point
double O four percent and a similar
progress was then experienced in the
United States in Malaysia and here we
have Ethiopia health for the greatest
proximate cause of death for most of
human history was infectious disease
that is largely eliminated as a cause of
death in the developed world in the
developing world it is still a major
killer but tremendous progress has been
made there just in the last twenty years
the rate of childhood deaths from the
five most deadly infectious diseases has
all been in decline pneumonia diarrhea
malaria measles and hiv/aids sustenance
it takes about 2,500 calories to sustain
a an active adult meal on an average and
it was only with the British
agricultural revolution in the second
half of the 18th century that the first
country was able to exceed that measure
thanks to advances in agronomy like crop
rotation later to the invention of
synthetic fertilizers
the mechanization of Agriculture the
selective breeding of vigorous hybrids
and networks of transportation every
region of the world has developed the
ability to feed itself here you have the
graph for the world as a whole now this
would be a dubious form of progress if
all those extra calories were just
making fat people fatter but in fact
they have greatly reduced the rate of
undernourishment in 1970 about 35% of
the developing world was undernourished
that has been cut down to less than 15%
again the spread of that progress has
been uneven Latin America was the first
region in the developing world to
decimate undernourishment here you have
three regions in Asia and here is
progress in sub-saharan Africa also
thanks to the availability of calories
famine which was one of the Horsemen of
the Apocalypse
could strike any continent and cause
sudden devastation has been reduced and
famines today are found mainly in
war-torn and remote regions prosperity
for most of human history there was
little to no economic growth this graph
shows the gross world product from the
year 1 to the Year 2015
and as you can see not much happened
until the Industrial Revolution in the
19th century and there's been a 200 fold
increase in gross world product since
the early 18th century again there the
progress has been highly uneven the UK
was the first country to make the what
Angus Deaton calls the great escape from
universal wretchedness and poverty the
United States quickly exceeded it here
we have South Korea and Asia Chile and
China and India are now showing
exponential growth the gross the GDP per
capita in India today is about what
Sweden had in 1920 once again this would
be a dubious example of progress if all
of the gains went to the one-percent
richest but in fact they have
drastically brought down the rate of
extreme poverty a dollar 90 per person
per day in 2015 dollars the bare minimum
necessary to feed one's family by that
definition about 90% of the world's
population was extreme extremely poor
200 years ago that has been brought down
to less than 10 percent and there's been
a 75 percent reduction in the rate of
extreme poverty just since 1999 because
poor countries are getting richer faster
than rich countries are getting richer
the the index of international
inequality there's inequality between
countries has started to decrease it
necessarily increased during the
industrial revolution when some
countries broke away from the pack of a
universal poverty but now more recently
the tide has begun to turn now within
rich countries of course inequality has
increased but that does not mean that
developed countries have turned their
backs on the poor in recent years quite
the contrary
for hundreds of years no European or
developed country spent more than 1.5
percent of its GDP on readest
redistribution to the poor the aged
children the sick
but in the course of the 20th century
every developed country embarked on a
massive program of redistribution so
that today the median among OECD
countries in social transfers is 22%
thanks largely to these transfers the
rate of poverty in the United States has
decreased even as inequality has
increased in 1960 the poverty rate when
it's calculated as disposable income
that is after taxes and transfers was 32
percent that has fallen to 7 percent and
when poverty is measured in terms of
consumption where people can afford to
buy it's gone from 30 percent to less
than 3 percent
peace for most of human history war was
the natural state of relations between
countries and peace was a mere interlude
between wars you can see this in this
graph which plots the percentage of
years that the great powers of the day
the 800-pound gorillas the empires and
states that could project military force
beyond their borders were at war with
each other in the 1500s and 1600s the
great powers were pretty much always at
war today they are virtually never at
war the last great power war pitted the
United States against China 65 years ago
if we zoom in on the 20th century then
of course two of the wars that did occur
were horrific bloodbath
but thanks to after the Second World War
thanks to expanding economies denser
commercial relations between countries
and norms against conquest and the
changing of borders by force the rate of
death in wars of all kinds has skittered
downwards there were peaks for the
Korean War the Vietnam War the iran-iraq
war and most recently the Syrian civil
war but the rate has come down from 22
per hundred thousand per year in the
late 40s and early 50s to about nine
during the Vietnam era to about five
during the iran-iraq war to
one point two today freedom and rights
there has been recently conspicuous
backsliding in democracy in countries
like Russia and Turkey and Venezuela but
still the overall trend in governance
has been towards democracy as this graph
showing the relative democracy versus
autocracy score across the world shows
but even with the backsliding in
democracy of recent years the world has
never been more democratic than it has
been in this decade and less that's
strike you as an incredible keep in mind
that in 200 years ago the number of
democracies in the world could be
counted on one hand and embraced one
percent of the world's population
as recently as the early 1970s the world
only had 31 democracies half of Europe
was behind the Iron Curtain and under
the control of communist totalitarian
dictatorships Spain and Portugal were
literally fascist dictatorships Greece
was under the control of the Colonel's a
military junta almost all of Latin
America was under the control of
military governments Taiwan South Korea
Indonesia all military governments all
and all of them today are democracies
they were about 52 democracies sorry
about 52 democracies in 1989 87 in 2009
the first year of the Obama presidency
when by the time Obama left office there
were a hundred and three democracies in
the world comprising 56 percent of the
world's population also the power of
governments to brutalize their citizens
is being curtailed capital punishment
used to be pretty much ubiquitous across
countries and it was applied to trivial
misdemeanors like shoplifting and
poaching often in grisly torture torture
executions like disembowelment and
burning at the stake but beginning with
the Enlightenment and swelling to a
flood in the 20th century country after
country has abolished the death penalty
if current trends continue the death
penalty will vanish
the earth by 2026 also more and more
countries have decriminalized
homosexuality again there has been
backsliding in Russia and several
African countries but overwhelmingly the
trend is towards decriminalization child
labour in 1850 30 percent of English
children were sent to work on in farms
and factories with the growth of
affluence a premium that modern
economies put on education and in
general evaluation of the lives of
children the rate of child labour has
plunged in England in the United States
even more dramatically in Italy and it's
come down in the world as a whole an
accomplishment for which kailashi trt
won the Nobel Peace Prize
three years ago violent crime pretty
much any region of the world in a state
of Anarchy suffers from high rates of
interpersonal violence records for
homicide go back in Europe some almost
800 years and in 1300 in Western
European countries had a homicide rate
of about 33 per a35 400,000 per year
with the consolidation of centralized
states and kingdoms across the medieval
patchwork of Berenice and fiefs the rate
of homicide came down in England and the
Netherlands from 35 to 1 a similar
reduction in Italy and pretty much any
part of the world in which frontier
regions come under the control of the
rule of law we'll see a transition from
high rates of violence to relatively low
ones as the code of vendetta and a
culture of Honor is replaced by a court
system in the rule of law
it happened in later in colonial New
England it happened in the American Wild
West when the when the sheriffs came to
town and even countries that remain
notorious for their high rates of
violence such as Mexico have seen a
fivefold decline of violence from what
it was 70 or 80 years ago we zoom in on
the last 50 years we see that the United
States which has with
many measures of human flourishing is
something of a an outlier among Western
democracies we we punched below our
wealth in measures of human well-being
and Indian in the United States and in
other Western countries there was
something of a crime boom in the 1960s
but starting in 1992 the United States
brought its rate of homicide down by
more than half and the world as a whole
has reduced its homicide rate by about
30 percent just in the last 20 years
there is a plan from the University of
Cambridge of how the world could reduce
its homicide rate by 50 percent in the
next 30 years and that's a quite a
feasible goal other kinds of violent
crime have also been in decline the
domestic violence such as violence
against wives and girlfriends rape and
sexual assault are down 75 percent since
the records were first kept in the 1970s
children are safer they're safer from
violent victimization at school
including bullying and safer from
physical abuse and sexual abuse by
caregivers in fact we've been getting
safer in just about every way thanks to
advances in safety technology in cars
like seatbelts and airbags thanks to the
design of better highways and more
consistent enforcement of traffic laws
the chance of B of being killed in a car
accident has fallen by 96% in the last
century we are eighty eight percent less
likely to be mowed down on the sidewalk
99% less likely to die in a plane crash
fifty-nine percent less likely to fall
to our deaths 90 percent less likely to
drown 92 percent less likely to die by
fire fire departments by the way are
putting themselves out of business 92%
less likely to be asphyxiated however
there is one category of accidental
death that has gone the other way that
is the category called poison by solid
or liquid and here you see the the
results of the American opioid epidemic
at the same time we're 95% less likely
to be killed on the job and what about
the acts of God the droughts floods wild
fires storms volcanoes landslides meteor
strikes earthquakes thanks to more
resilient infrastructure better early
warning systems and better emergency
responses were 96% less likely to be to
die in an act of God because it will be
not because god has become more merciful
indeed think about the quintessential
act of God the everyone's favorite
metaphor for an unpredictable date with
death the literal bolt from the blue yes
we are 97% less likely to be killed by a
bolt of lightning knowledge we are
naturally illiterate and even in early
modern Europe no more than 15% of the
population could read and write European
countries achieve universal literacy by
the mid 20th century Germany a little
bit later
here you see Italy the United States
Chile and Mexico here you have the
trajectory for the world as a whole
showing that today 80 percent of the
world can read or write and 90 percent
of the world under the age of 25 not
just boys but girls in 1750 only six
girls could read or write for every ten
boys and that gender parity was achieved
in the late 19th century the world as a
whole is very close to gender parity in
literacy even the most backward parts of
the world Pakistan and Afghanistan have
shown dramatic increases for which we
can thank the other winner of the Nobel
Peace Prize in 2015 Malala yousufzai and
in perhaps the most incredible example
of progress of all the one that defies
belief that people their jaws drop we
have been getting smarter this is true
in a well-documented effect known as the
Flynn effect IQ scores all over the
world have increased by three points per
decade for a century a gift of the
spread of education
but also of the trickling down of
abstract concepts and visual symbols
from technical domains like science and
technology to everyday experience well
have these gains improved our quality of
life in many ways they have in 1870 the
typical work week in the United States
and Western Europe was greater than the
62 years that has fallen by 22 ow
62 hours per week that is that's fallen
by 22 hours a week and in addition most
American workers get three weeks of paid
vacation thanks to the universal
penetration of running water and
electricity and to the adoption of what
used to be called labor saving devices
like washing machines vacuum cleaners
refrigerators dishwashers stoves and
microwaves
the amount of our life that we lose to
housework has fallen from 62 hours a
week to less than 15 hours a week that
is from about eight hours a day to two
hours a day and when I say we I really
should say women because housework is
highly gendered given that housework is
the activity that people rate as the
least favorite way to spend their time
this itself is an enormous gain in
quality of life thanks to shorter work
weeks and less time lost to housework
leisure time has increased by about
eight hours a week just since 1965 the
game for women started to level off
around 1995 and I was puzzled by this
graph and read the fine print and the
tables and the reason for the leveling
off is that women are spending more time
with their children so a single working
mother today spends more time with their
children then a married stay-at-home mom
did in the 1950s so forget the
stereotypes from Leave It to Beaver now
is the time when women are spending more
time with their children
we also forfeit less of our paycheck to
necessities from sixty percent a century
ago to less than a third today has it
made us any happier
it's often said that money can't buy
happiness but that's not exactly true if
you look at a graph of self-rated life
satisfaction as a function of GDP per
capita on a logarithmic scale
you see there's actually a pretty strong
relationship both within across
countries as indicated by the
scatterplot of points and within
countries as indicated by the arrows
impaling each point again it's a
logarithmic scale which means the
relationship starts to bend over when
you get to higher income levels but what
this graph suggests is that as countries
get richer as all countries are doing
their citizens are likely to get happier
and indeed the world value survey has
found that in 45 of the 52 countries
they have tracked 86% happiness as
increased over the last 40 years has it
come at the expense of the environment
and the answer is it surely has although
that is starting to turn around
according to a report card given to
countries called the environmental
performance index 178 out of 180
countries have shown improvements in
environmental quality over the last few
decades I'll just show you a snapshot of
what's happened in the United States
since 1970 thanks to the year of the
formation of the Environmental
Protection Agency thanks to legislation
that regulates pollution and to
pollution control technology while the
American population is increased by 40%
GDP has increased by a factor of two and
a half we've driven twice as many miles
but the five major air pollutants have
been reduced by 60 percent so the idea
that is conventional wisdom both on the
extreme libertarian right and in the
extreme green left that we have to
choose between economic growth and
environmental protection I turns out to
be false
deforestation in temperate regions of
the world has fallen to zero as forests
are no longer cleared for farms and
abandoned farms are in fact being
recolonized by temperate forests the
situation is not as rosy and when it
comes to tropical forests where there is
still alarming deforestation but the
tide has turned and the peak for
deforestation was more than 40 years ago
and it has come down since 1970 the
world has shipped twice as much oil by
sea but has had 85 percent fewer oil
spills and the amount of the Earth's
surface that's protected against
economic exploitation has doubled from 8
percent to 15 percent while the amount
of the world's oceans that are protected
has also doubled from 6% to 12% well I
hope to have convinced you that that
progress is not a matter of having a
sunny disposition but is an empirical
fact and how is the fact of human
progress reflected in the news well I'm
going to show you a graph that uses the
technique of sentiment mapping that
tallies the number of positive versus
negative words in a sample of new
stories going back to 1945 when it comes
to the New York Times during this era of
increasing peace prosperity and
happiness the New York Times has gotten
glomer and glomer and that is true of a
summary of the world's broadcasts as
well which has become increasingly
morose so why do people deny progress
part of the answer comes from cognitive
psychology Amos Tversky and Daniel
Kahneman have shown that the human brain
tends to estimate risk and probability
via a shortcut they call the
availability heuristic namely the more
easily we can recall examples from
memory the more common we think an event
is for people for example think that
tornados kill more people every year
than asthma attacks whereas it's
drastically the other way around
presumably because tornados make for
great television and
my attacks not so much indeed if you
combine the availability heuristic with
the nature of news recalling that news
is about stuff that happens not stuff
that doesn't happen you never see a
journalist saying Here I am reporting
live from a country that is not at war
or a city that has not been attacked by
terrorists also news is about sudden
events not gradual changes as The
Economist track max Rosa points out the
news could have report it had run the
headline 138 thousand people escaped
from extreme poverty yesterday every day
for the last 25 years but they never ran
that headline leading to the story in
the hypothetical story in the onion
CNN holds morning meaning meeting to
decide what viewers should panic about
for the rest of the day you combine the
availability heuristic with the nature
of the news and you get the impression
that the world is getting more dangerous
and always has been there's another
feature of our psychology that
predisposes us to pessimism about the
world called a negativity bias that bad
is stronger than good we dread losses
more than we anticipate gains we dwell
more on what can go wrong than what can
go right especially recent bad events
bad events that in distant memory tend
to lose their negative coloring
explaining an observation by Franklin
Pierce Adams that nothing is more
responsible for the good old days than a
bad memory
the negativity bias also opens up a
market for doomsayers and profits to
remind us of hazards we may have
overlooked as a result pessimism often
sounds serious
optimism sounds frivolous as Morgan
Housel a financial writer to point out
pessimist sound like they're trying to
help you
optimist sound like they're trying to
sell you something there's also a Status
competition among elites Society is
divided into different professional
guilds and clubs with different
responsibilities for making the society
run to complain about modern society is
a backhanded way of putting down your
professional rivals it's a way for
academics to look down on business
people for business people to look down
on politicians for political challengers
to look down on incumbents and so on
this has been going on for quite some
time as Thomas Hobbes said in the 17th
century competition of praise inclined
us to a reverence of antiquity for men
contend with the living not with the
dead let me end with three questions
about progress and enlightenment you
might think isn't it good to be
pessimistic to afflict the comfortable
to break the mock to speak truth to
power well not exactly
it's good to be accurate of course we
must be aware of problems and suffering
and injustice where they occur but it's
also important to be aware of how they
can be reduced there are dangers to
thoughtless pessimism such as fatalism
why throw good money after bad why throw
money down a rat hole the poor will
always be with you why waste time and
money on a hopeless cause indeed if we
are doomed as many prophets remind us
then we should just enjoy life while we
can since there's nothing that we can do
to to forestall that do eat drink and be
merry for tomorrow we die it can also
open the door to radicalism if every
institution is in irrevocable decline if
the society is degenerating fast
on the verge of collapse well that opens
up calls to smash the Machine drain the
swamp burn the empire to the ground
under the expectation that anything
rising out of the ashes has got to be
better than what we have today or to
empower an aspiring demagogue who
promises only I can fix it is progress
inevitable well of course not
progress does not mean that everything
gets better for everyone everywhere all
the time that would be magic not
progress progress consists of using
knowledge to solve problems and problems
are inevitable solutions create new
problems which have to be solved in
their turn also the world can always be
blindsided by nasty surprises and I've
mentioned a number of them the world
wars the 1960's crime boom AIDS in
Africa the American opioid epidemic and
there are severe global challenges that
we have not solved for most among them
being climate change and the risk of
nuclear war I think it is best to see
these not as apocalypses in waiting but
as solvable but as yet unsolved problems
we can address climate change by
attempts to decarbonize our economy via
carbon pricing and lo zero and negative
carbon technologies and to pursue
denuclearization via international
stability which would make nuclear
weapons unneeded obsolete anachronistic
and programs of arms reduction just a
couple of hints that these are not vain
utopian hopes is the fact that in some
ways they have already begun there's a
natural arc in modern economies toward
emitting less co2 per dollar of GDP here
we have a graph for the UK showing that
as the UK underwent the Industrial
Revolution it emitted far more co2 as
large amounts of coal were burned to
power the Industrial Revolution
but then there was a transition from
coal to oil from oil to natural gas from
and then to renewables and nuclear
energy and hydro which has resulted in
less co2 being emitted per unit of
wealth the u.s. underwent the same
transition China did with huge spikes
from the Maoist era where people were
forced to set up backyard smelters that
emitted vast amounts of co2 with zero
economic output and but it started to
come down as it has for India and the
world as a whole now I have to emphasize
this does not mean that the climate will
have a soft landing those figures have
to go down to zero which is an
extraordinary challenge but it shows
that economies are not inherently tied
to flaming carbon the major fact about
nuclear weapons is that no nuclear
weapon has been used in war since
Nagasaki more than 70 years ago and
there is a something like a taboo
against the use of nuclear weapons even
at least so far including Street
tactical nuclear weapons and there's
been a massive reduction in the size of
the world's arsenal at least so far at
85 percent reduction since the height of
the Cold War in the 1980s indeed about
10 percent of American electricity is
generated from fuel nuclear fuel from
spent nuclear weapons in mainly Soviet
more generally progress is not a
mystical force but it depends on
embracing the ideals of the
Enlightenment namely applying reason in
science to enhance human flourishing if
we continue to apply these principles
then progress could continue and if we
don't it may not final question does the
Enlightenment go against human nature as
some romantics and defenders of religion
insist is humanism just too arid or
tepid or flattened to satisfy human
needs is the conquest of disease famine
poverty violence and
it's boring do people need to believe in
miracles a father in the sky a strong
chief to protect the tribe myths of
heroic ancestors well it's not so clear
secular liberal democracies turn out to
be the happiest and healthiest places on
earth probably in the history of our
species and they are the top destination
of people who vote with their feet also
oh yeah I dare say that applying
knowledge and sympathy to enhance human
flourishing is heroic glorious maybe
even spiritual this is a heroic story
that is not just a myth it is true or
true to the best of our knowledge which
is the only truth we can have also it is
a heroic story that doesn't belong to
one tribe but to all of humanity - to
any sentient being with the power of
reason and the drive to persist in its
being because it depends only on the
convictions that life is better than
death health is better than sickness
abundance is better than want freedom is
better than coercion happiness is better
than suffering and knowledge is better
than superstition and ignorance thank
you very much
thank you all right
[Applause]
my first note says remember to mention
post-show book sales thank you out there
you haven't mentioned Trump except by
certain inference but essentially he is
mentioned you book quite a lot and you
see me saying that one of the ways to
these various success curves can be
reversed as to the policies of
administration you want to spell that
out a bit yes well I faced a challenge
in writing a book on progress that came
out and after 2016
shortly after 2016 it doesn't look like
so much progress and I got I got
conflicting advice
some people said oh he's just a blip
progress is gonna continue you want your
book to be relevant long after he's left
the stage don't mention him your other
said well you should after every measure
of progress that you document you should
say but this is threatened if Donald
Trump gets his way so I I didn't follow
either bit of advice but I did try to
put the trumpism in perspective in a
couple of ways one is first of all it is
undoubtedly true that all of almost all
of the measures that I attributed
progress to are really under threat from
from Trump's policies the international
community of both of commercial
connections through trade and strong
international norms and associations
like the like like the UN like the
ability to impose sanctions to countries
that violate the taboo against conquest
are threatened the regulations that have
made technology safer that have allowed
environmental protection to the
environment to be protected as the
economy has grown a reliance on science
and evidence both as a way to expand
extend to human life
span and to implement policies like
crime reduction that are driven by
evidence I mean I could go hunt they
really are threatened it isn't just the
standard liberals discussed with Donald
Trump I pinpoint why each one of these
causes of progress really really has
been threatened so a question is is um
the one thing does that mean that
trumpism and authoritarian populist and
more generally are the wave of the wave
of the future so have we was progress
nice while it lasted
but the Enlightenment is over and the
clocks gonna be turned back well I mean
no one knows but there are some reasons
to think not that's a little premature
to declare the enlightenment dead among
them are that a lot of these these
processes are trends that have been in
progress for four decades
and it seems unlikely that they will
suddenly do a u-turn for what that's
worth including just the political and
and sentiments toward liberalism one
graph that I chose not to show tonight
comes from the World Values Survey and
it looks at attitudes of Tolerance
women's rights Politico Craddock
political participation in every region
of the world they've been going up since
1960 so that's more than more than 50
years big differences across regions but
with the Middle East to North Africa the
world's least liberal region in Western
Europe most but there has been a steady
increase in every region of the world
this is driven by urbanization by
education by connectivity forces that
are themselves not likely to stop
overnight also if you look at the age
distribution of support for populism I
have a graph that shows the degree of
support for Donald Trump in 2016 breaks
it in 2016 and European populist parties
over the last 15 years and they all kind
of fall off a cliff as a function of age
now people contrary to the old cliche
that if you're not a liberal when you're
20 you have no heart if you are a
liberal when you're 60 you have no head
attributed to many people that that
turns out to be false people basically
carry their liberalism with them as they
age which suggests that populism is
something of a middle-aged and old man's
movement and the demographics are likely
to push against it a related demographic
question is immigration is a big event
mmm specially in Europe North America
our immigrants more liberal or what it
depends a lot on the immigrants in and
in fact some of the rise of populism is
due not to I think a retreat from
enlightenment values but to the specific
incident of huge waves of immigration
from parts of the world that are the
least liberal Middle East and North
Africa often not assimilating quickly
and bringing a lot of counter
Enlightenment values with them such as
when we just fundamentalism and
oppression of women and there has been a
backlash against that massive
immigration that has empowered some of
the right-wing populists in Europe the
other the other thing I do in dealing
with populism and trumpism is to note
that this is actually not the first time
that enlightenment values have been
resisted even though it sounds like an
oxymoron to talk about the intellectual
roots of trumpism but
and at first I thought that that that
trumpism was just kind of pure it just
streaks of human nature from
authoritarianism tribalism demonization
that you know always push back against
enlightenment too and I think there is
something to that
I think the Enlightenment is not so
cognitively natural tribalism really is
a recurring motive but there actually is
Trump was advised by people like Steve
Madden Michael Anton Steve Miller who
consider themselves intellectuals they
are consider themselves well-read and
they were influenced by counter
Enlightenment political thinkers and
philosophers by crackpot French and
Italian fascists from the 1910s in the
1920s from Friedrich Nietzsche who was a
rabidly counter Enlightenment figure
mm-hmm and pretty soon after the
Enlightenment unfolded there was a
resistance movement a kind of romantic
counter Enlightenment nationalist
tribalist blood and soil devaluing the
individual in favor of the culture the
tribe the land the bloodline and it
gained descendants in various times of
European history especially in Central
Europe around the time of World War one
in World War two it was in abeyance
after World War two because the world
sort of saw what it leads to and but but
it does tend to bubble up and that's
what we've been seeing I think without
with authoritarian populism a couple of
questions about the research that what
we just saw reflects kreygas how do you
perform your research to ensure the
statistics you use aren't affected by an
implicit bias toward data that shows
positive progress and I would add to
that I can't believe you did all this
research so you'll see a little bit
about how you accumulated the material
is behind these graphs which is you know
that yeah really meat of what you have
here from from various places I was
assisted greatly by a couple of
websites that have popped up that are
kind of data aggregators max roeser's
work website our world and data
stupendous source of data because not
only are there graphs but you can
download them and link to the original
source of each one off often United
Nations organizations the Food and
Agricultural organization of the World
Health Organization the World Bank
there's another one by Mari and 2p
called human progress org there's Hans
and Ola Rosling's website Gapminder
mm-hmm so that was a kind of portal into
some of the standard data sets and
others I've found from various sources
by often if I read a large number of
books by experts in the particular
domains and recorded their references
and follow up on their data sets and I
don't think any of the any of the
sources that I cite are particularly
controversial in terms of their their
direction that is you could quibble
about exact values but but I would be
surprised if any of them were were not
the consensus of the academic experts in
each field so I think it's pretty well
established among historical
criminologists for example that there's
been a massive reduction in homicide
since the middle ages I think all the ex
Craig's question sure how do you defeat
your own confirmation bias well if by
looking at curves that go in the wrong
direction like the opioid epidemic like
the great American crime boom in there
or not just American Western crime boom
in the in the 60s 70s and 80s if that
graph stayed high that would be a
counter example to progress in that
domain if if the graph for deaths and
Wars was a world war one and then World
War two and then World War three I know
that would be dis confirmation so
anything could be just confirmed that's
easy the fact is the graphs do go down
like that
I should think she actually if I were
you I'd be welcoming anything that is
sort of counter to these trends because
they're so continuous wide and gross and
so and then you know anything goes
against it you sir
in order to add some kind of
plausibility true another another
example for those who are kind of
eagle-eyed very very quick grapha
spotters may have seen a number of
reversals such as the fact that the
American homicide rate which fell pretty
steadily from 1992 to 2014 went up in
2015 and 2016 I mean not didn't undo the
decline but wiped out about nine years
of progress and the Syrian civil war
represents a reversal the the peak was
probably the year before last
let's hope but that was a way to the
wrong direction in fact in the book I
have four graphs for violence I put a
little arrow pointing to the last year
of data plotted in my previous book the
better angels of our nature to address
the question well did you maybe catch
the world at a lucky moment and has it
all fallen apart since then and in a
couple of cases like the the optic in
American homicide it has gone in the
other direction the Syrian civil war
again was a blip up from the low from
2010 so the you know the graphs could go
any which way and you're right they it
would be if they all just went
monotonically downward mistrusting
suitably creepy toy from the United
Nations Innovation Lab - where does
female empowerment and leadership fit
into this new era of enlightenment yeah
it's it's actually a theme that I
explored more in the better angels of
our nature than in this book just the
question that people often ask about
violence is as women are more empowered
would you expect rates of violence to go
down the answer is probably yes
and in the case in the broader case of
human flourishing
I didn't comment on this but it does
seem that there is a in the switch from
say martial values tribalism national
glory to humanism you could say this is
a kind of feminized a
of morality that a world in which it's
safe to bring up children you know who
grow up look at an education who don't
die of disease it'll starve to death as
opposed to the glory of the nation you
could say that that's a shift from
prototypically masculine to more
feminine values and it may not be a
coincidence that many of these changes
have been coincident with the rising
empowerment of women since since the
1970s how is that going in your world of
academia which is famously slow - well
it's actually hasn't been slow to
feminize I mean there are some there is
a students but other than the power
structure well no it depends on the
discipline ok say more I'm a
psychologist our our discipline is doing
pretty well for gender parity in fact my
main area of specialization was language
development in children which was
majority female mm-hmm psychology is one
of the more closer to closer to gender
parity not exactly and it's depending on
the discipline there's a enormous
differences in the percentage of
scientists who are female ok ah here's a
live stream question from unfriend phew
Howie live stream I recommend to folks I
just started trying it myself and on
live stream you see the slides better
than you see it in the theater and
questions come to the stage so Hugh
Howey yes how does the balance of
knowledge that things are getting better
and passion required to continue the
trends blend how do we manage make it
easier for people to be rational
pessimists and optimistic activists is
people sir sit back say the things are
gonna be ok
I had to go golf yeah you know I don't
know if that's happened in fact I'm
doing planning to experiments with a
student of mine Jason de Muro - to see
whether narratives of decline and
degeneration or narratives of
conditional progress are more likely to
empower people to donate effectively to
charity to not to discount the future as
much so we don't know for sure my my
hunch is that there is an optimal amount
of pessimism and that many people are
more pessimistic than the optimum and I
don't know if this is true it's an
empirical question I just know it so you
should never do this but of course we
all do just for my own experience I feel
I've been more of a donor to charities
more of an activist more spoken out more
since I've seen all of the ways in which
humanity has increased its human
activity can pay off in things actually
getting better it's not just feeling
good it's not just conspicuous virtual
six signaling but trying to make the
world better makes a little better and I
appreciate that more have you yourself
over the course of these last couple of
kinds of research books shifted your own
personal relationship to the world from
a less pessimistic to a more optimistic
absolutely and in fact there's a there's
a paper trail because in 2002 I wrote a
book called the blank slate on the
modern denial of human nature and a
belief in human nature has tended to
militate toward a kind of tragic view of
the human condition were we're not
angels we can never have in Utopia on
the other hand as a cognitive
psychologist my view of human nature
always accommodated a system of our
brain that can creatively combine new
ideas someone who studies language I
know that we can share our hard-won
wisdom through through words and so
there is scope for human improvement
even with a belief in human nature
namely we come up with new ideas we try
them we share them we keep the ones that
work but I think since between writing
the blank slate defending human nature
and the better angels of our nature
which was inspired by stumbling across
graphs showing declines of in violence
I've become more
optimistic based on the data and more
and I think more engaged in effective
altruism and advocacy of a positive
change this is an interesting measure if
you looked at activists across the board
and we're sort of evaluating their
effectiveness as as activists in the
domain that they care about and then
measure their effectiveness as activists
in that domain against their pessimism
or optimism is anybody looking to see
what makes an effective activist and
there's this part of that story that I
would love to do with the answer so I
mean I I suspect that that effect of all
activists are do have some enough at
least enough optimism enough animal
spirits as Keynes put it to take the
risks under uncertainty to make the
personal sacrifices under some
reasonable expectation that they'll
return benefits to human welfare okay
this is speculation I think it says
something that should be studied I have
a question in the language here that
you're this language guy you know we
call it optimism and pessimism and when
there's an optimist or pessimist it's so
like a Communists and communist and
there's this a belief structure we're
talking about or what yes
well if this goes back to a belief in
human nature I'm virtually certain that
a big chunk of differences among people
in level of optimism versus pessimism is
heritable I just cuz everything is it's
partly heritable and and there are
certain personality traits that would
tend to correlate with optimism
pessimism that we know are heritable
such as neuroticism which is a degree of
worry then correlating so who's more
neurotic oh the pessimist but you know
optimism that the term optimism I think
it actually does go back to the era of
live knits and Voltaire and an optimist
was someone who believed that this is
the best of all possible worlds namely
this is the optimum and ironically
enough of Voltaire was actually not
satirizing what I never got that
optimism is optimism which actually is
not the way we not the way we use the
word now
as I mentioned if you're really an
optimist you don't think that this is
the optimum heaven forbid so when I was
professor I don't know where pessimism
how they'll find out but in any case
Voltaire wasn't even satirizing hopes
for a better future and he was an
Enlightenment figure he was satirizing
almost the opposite Leibniz theodicy
according to which we have no choice but
to accept the evil and violence and
suffering and early death in the world
because it's metaphysically impossible
for the world to be any better than it
is because if it could be better God
would have made it better
mm-hmm so what we have we're stuck with
it's impossible for the world to be
better that's what Leibniz had in mind
and that's what Voltaire was satirizing
speaking of that there's a question from
a person named anonymous who says is
there asked is there a religious
component from monotheism which helped
order to be considered helping modern
enlightenment and science and quality of
life
well the certainly the Enlightenment
thinkers themselves were even though
they many of them were not atheists some
of the more deists they believe that God
kind of wild up the clock of the
universe set it in motion and then let
it kind of unwind by itself without any
intervention none of them really
appealed to judeo-christian doctrine to
justify much of anything
in fact often the Enlightenment is
almost defined as a abandonment of
justification by Scripture dogma
tradition mm-hmm there there is a notion
of progress in among religious thinkers
that may have influenced the
Enlightenment the idea that there has
been progress from at least among
Christian thinkers from the ancient
Hebrews to the Jesus to the early church
to the if your parson to the Reformation
so there is that notion that at least
concept of progress but it's uh well
these churches were an institution are
they an institution in the Enlightenment
sense that you've been talking about
it's a sort of a no Amelia reader of a
lot of the fragment and feudal like
some of them especially that the
Catholic Church fought the Enlightenment
tooth and nail Josef - Miska for example
was a argued against the abolition of
torture and and grisly torture
executions because people will just run
wild with licentiousness if they don't
have the fear of being tortured to death
he's against reading of novels because
then people would start to get ideas
about nonconformity so certainly the
Catholic Church was dead set again and
actually in many ways continues to be
and then many of our much of the what
you might think of as sort of strange
opposition to enlightenment including
some of the negative reviews of
enlightenment now come from prom cap
prominent intellectuals who would be the
first to note that they are influenced
by Catholicism such as Andrew Sullivan
such as Ross Douthat
and there's been a queasiness among many
Catholic thinkers - Steve Bannon another
Catholic thinker mmm - the idea that and
again he's me makes no bones about it
he's he address the Vatican and one of
his most famous speeches was delivered
there the idea that the individual human
is the both the locus of moral value
valuation that what's important is how
happy each one of us is that the human
reason is the source of moral doctrine
as opposed to something that is bigger
than any of us namely the church and the
church tradition that the freedom and
individual self-determination have just
led to licentiousness to pornography and
abortion and divorce so there has been a
attention between enlightenment and at
least some religious traditions others
though have been influenced by the
Enlightenment in many religious
denominations have become more
humanistic more liberal Quakerism was in
some ways ahead of the curve
they were both abolitionists and
pacifists in an era where not all
Enlightenment thinkers were and
certainly most other religious
denominations were not and other
denominations mainstream Protestantism
the more liberal branches of Judaism
have I think been affected by the
Enlightenment tide and have backtracked
from the Iron Age morality from the
theological doctrines and have become
kind of institutions of humanism
themselves you're among the sort of
public somewhat aggressive atheists I'm
clear I mean I I have the statement
there's no evidence that God exists I
think that I think that's a true
statement I don't mean aggressive it's
perceived as aggressive I think
precisely because it is only by faith
tribe community bloodline that you have
beliefs almost by definition that are
based on faith and so if you simply put
those beliefs under a rational
microscope it sounds like you're
attacking the people who acquired those
beliefs because of the community that
they were born into so that's where I
think the perception of aggression comes
from even though it's just a hypothesis
and you know why can't I say there's no
evidence if there's no evidence so house
atheism doing on or near church well
there's they're two different trends has
a by the way and I have to quote here
Bertrand Russell who's when he was
challenged on there by some vicar on the
BBC like well what will you say if after
you die you find yourself staring the
Almighty in the face and he said Oh Lord
why did you not give me more evidence
but back to your question and the Lord
says what part of the word face do you
not understand there are two trends that
are going in opposite directions
one of them is that when people shift
their religious belief it is in the
direction of losing their religion the
fastest-growing religion in terms of
converts is no religion at all
however religious people have more
babies so the number of people that are
in communities of faith is increasing
even though the number of people who
become religious is decreasing the other
trend that makes us overestimate the the
influence of religion why many people
believe that despite enlightenment hopes
people are getting that religion is
playing a larger and larger role I'm an
aside from just here for fecundity which
itself may change in the future as
because a lot of the trends that have
reduced religiosity hmm like
urbanization like like education like
affluence as those continue they also
affect fertility and so it could be that
the trend toward the demographic
transition to lower fertility may also
involve secularization but the other I
think distorter of our perception of the
role of religion is that religious
people vote and and a lot of second
people do not why do religious people
vote partly their their clergy tell them
to it may also be I mean that may be one
reason and so in fact in the 2016
election I think the voting rate among
evangelical Christians was in the
ballpark of 80 percent the voting rate
among so-called nuns you know any
it was more like 25% now partly this is
age there's a pretty big cohort effect
for religiosity the younger the group
the less religious but then it may also
be that whatever social cultural
personality type allows you to affiliate
with any institution makes you more
engaged in the political process and
that some of the nuns aren't so much
kind of students of Bertrand Russell who
figured it all out but they just kind of
withdraw from all institutions from
churches but also from the political
process okay here's the internet
question social media question Justin
asks how do you feel about communication
over the Internet has affected our
ability to have discourses and
advancement and where does it fit into
this story do you think yes so that's
the music nowadays everything that goes
wrong is blamed on social media right
right and you know maybe some of the
things that have gone wrong our fault of
social media then some surely our yeah
and I don't really know that's I think
it's to man but by that I mean who cares
what I know it is not know in the sense
that it's so new that I don't think
there's a good body of literature on how
much social media has driven the
polarization that we have seen a lot of
it has been driven by cable news and
there we do know that it has an effect
just by the natural experiment that
cable companies offer different menus of
stations and Fox News in particular is
sometimes introduced to one town before
it's introduced to another town so for
social scientists yes it independent
very an experiment of nature and what
happens is there is absolutely an effect
of Fox News on voting and political
opinions when Fox News is introduced to
a town the citizens move to the right
and so that's not social media but man
is in effect there's also a big effect
and again I don't know if if we have the
social science data to disentangle them
but segregation by education
and that more highly educated people
tend to live with one another more
mm-hmm
there patterns across urban areas versus
suburbs some here am saying this in San
Francisco it's kind of bloody obvious
and that the like-minded communities may
be driven by physical proximity and by
occupational segregation as far as you
know as much as by social media filter
bubbles there's a couple of where we go
from here questions Alexander Rose asks
what trends our data give you the most
concern Emily asks where should we focus
our efforts for progress in the future
in your opinion yeah well you know there
may be separate questions they may be
related they might be relation about
what should we should we focus wealthy
certainly in terms of actual physical
threats I'm concerned about climate
change
I assume you are too but maybe not as
much as me or more but I'm concerned
about climate change
mm-hmm I am concerned about the low
probability high damage scenario of a
nuclear war interesting okay not because
I think it's particularly likely but
just because it's if it does happen it's
it could be a lot of people could be
killed very quickly in the world of
ideas I am concerned about the rise of
authoritarian populism I as I said I
think there are demographic and trends
that are probably will prevent it from
taking over but in the meantime it
certainly has gained control of a number
of countries I'm concerned about
impediments to economic growth if the if
there are structural brakes on growth
like debt like an expanding retired
population supported by a shrinking
working population Japan yeah exactly
and one thing that surprised me as I
wrote the book is how many good things
come from economic growth
I mentioned happiness as one but the
Flynn effect of rising IQ scores is
affected by how a wealthy country is
liberal values richer countries in
general are more tolerant more
progressive more liberal at least if the
source of their wealth comes from
knowledge and commerce as opposed to
digging stuff out of the ground because
there are a number of extraction States
particularly in the Middle East Arab oil
States that are very rich and very
reactionary but putting aside them in
general wealth buys liberalism it buys
intelligence it by his happiness advice
peace it buys democracy on average
mmm-hmm so if economic growth were to
Plateau then a lot there'd be a lot of
negative consequences so that's
something I think about so one question
you enlightenment now new enlightenment
that was then this is now
you're talking about the values which
were established in and that are still
valid to push forward what's different
200 years is a long time and a whole
hell of a lot is going on and that we're
still even evoking something that was
basically invented over two hundred
years ago is itself strange and amazing
but okay go with that what is an
Enlightenment now made of it is are we
just seeing this is the Enlightenment
playing out quietly behind the scenes
making all these graphs go forward or is
there something extra-special of these
questions are raising there that we
might be doing now so that we are the
Voltaire's and deed arose and so on of
our time what are we talking about now
in terms of employment well now we we
certainly are talking about limiting the
resurgence of tribalism nationalism
racialism I think that in general
although I don't think that religion is
necessarily incompatible with
enlightenment value
because widgets become more lightened
but certainly fundamentalist beliefs
getting your morality from Scripture
getting your theory of causation from
scriptures so you're using prayer or
faith as a solution to problems I think
is probably problematic I'll be concrete
there is a belief there's a huge
correlation between utter denial of
human-made climate change and both right
left politics much greater correlate
correlation in a scientific literacy
fact the correlation of scientific
literacy is probably zero the
correlation with where you are on the
right left scale is very very high Oh
point eight or something or point nine
and there is a correlation with with
religiosity so there was a movement in
the 1990s and early and first few years
of the 21st century toward sometimes
called
stewardship of the environment kind of
confluence of the religious with the
environmental movement
I think it's called creation
environmentalism it went by a number of
names
it was completely dashed when Obama
became president and the Republican
Party vowed a principle of absolute
non-cooperation with anything the Obama
administration proposed and of course
evangelical Christians were locked up by
the Republican Party and so the the
dream edia Wilson had a whole book where
he had a letter to a hypothetical
Minister of how they could find common
cause and protecting God's gift of the
environment forget about it there was
just the evangelicals became implacably
opposed to any measures to address
carbon emissions or or environmental
protection and part of it was polls show
that a large percentage of them believe
God wouldn't alit let any bad thing
happen God wouldn't let there be climate
catastrophes so this is a case in which
a counter enlightened belief
Enlightenment belief could have real
pernicious consequences okay so in the
sense you're using concern about climate
as a sort
measure of enlightenment enlightenment
actually in people that would be one
example but it also sounds like you're
telling the outliers of this political
spectrum that if there were less out
lawyers and more folks sort of arguing
agreeably with each other rather than
totally not listening that that somehow
and movement in the right direction
I would so hard left or both problems I
would I think so yeah
the just from yeah just from research
that shows that when people are
committed to a political ideology they
are demonstrably less rational this has
been shown by a number of ways by Philip
tetlock who's spoken in this series has
shown that if you look at how accurately
people predict the future I mean you
know not kind of seen into the next
century but just I pull their feet to
the fire make concrete predictions about
what's gonna happen in the next six
months to a year the political idea all
I do is do much worse than the kind of
the Bayesian nerds the ones who try to
assess a base rate probability and tweak
it up or down by the evidence and
another example is the work of the Yale
legal scholar Daniel kahan who's did a
famous experiment it was reported in a
number of newspapers as why politics
makes us stupid or politics interferes
with with your ability to do math that
presenting data to people from a
hypothetical study what the data were
jiggered so that there was a kind of gut
feeling as to what they implied whether
a cause B that was wrong that is if you
look at the raw numbers it would seem
that a caused B but if you take a second
and just do the proportions then you
realize it's the other way around
so you know deliberately a little bit of
a trick question so it required a bit of
reflection if you if it's a non
political issue does this skin cream
successfully treat a rash then the more
numerate you are the less likely you are
to be seduced by the wrong answer both
if you're a liberal or a conservative
but as soon as the issue becomes
politicized namely does a concealed
carry law increase to reduce the crime
rate same numbers then turns out that
the more numerous liberals and
conservatives did worse when the data
went against their preferred hypothesis
and so politics makes us stupid and that
that's the basis of my expectation that
less polarization would lead to more
optimal policies how is that playing out
in academia know you've invaded against
over polarization of who can speak on
campus and so on III think it has
distorted certain issues in in academia
that was one theme of my book the blank
slate that a lot of issues in psychology
I think had been distorted by the fact
that certain answers were deemed
politically more acceptable and there
was a kind of blinkers toward data that
that contradicted it that was a theme
that was then taken up by Phil tetlock
again and John height and was a sort of
group of other Sheena's conservative
public intellectual academics well
conservative in the sense of the
perspective of what I got insanely
liberal what are we talking about it
well I refer to be a hypothetical
location called the left poles so when
you're you know when you're at the North
Pole all directions are south when
you're at the left Pole all directions
are right so from the left pole in
academia by that standard I like to call
the conservative but very peculiar
conservative I'm one of the biggest
donors among the Harvard faculty to the
Democratic Party and I voted for Hillary
I'm really by all by no stretch of the
imagination a conservative except by
this peculiar perspective of the left
pole is that getting better on campus or
worse by the way it's getting worse
that many that the point of the tetlock
height Duarte stern article was that the
kind of diversity that really advances
intellectual understanding and policy is
diversity of viewpoint mm-hmm and that
has been decreasing even in an era in
which diversity is celebrated as the
civil liberties lawyer Harvey solo great
put it in modern universities the
meaning of diversity is people who look
different but think alike and so what
the heterodox Academy which I'm
affiliated with and and John Hyde and
others have advocated is science will
advance if we have a diversity of
viewpoints simply because no one is
omniscient
no one is infallible science progresses
when hypotheses are floated the fee
incorrect ones are refuted by data and
if we only try hypotheses from a narrow
slice of the spectrum of possibilities
we're probably going to be wrong a lot
of the time okay I think I'll end with a
nice general question from Neal Goldberg
how do you relate contemporary China
which has made huge progress following
all these measures and you would not
exactly describe as an Enlightenment
Society so I'd say it's a yeah a
question and I don't I don't know the
answer but it is I think it is a
profound question certainly China as
repressive as it is and even more so
with the announcement a few days ago of
the apt removal of term limits for a Jew
Jinping it's certainly more has greater
degree of personal freedom than it did
in the era of Mao and and some
Enlightenment institutions like markets
were adopted by chilena to its enormous
benefit in terms of prosperity lifespan
so say probably they were adopting what
Lee Kuan Yew had done in Singapore that
was that enlightenment to the phenomenon
that we did there in one way yes and in
waise No so yes in terms of markets
which was a enlightenment innovation
compared to royal charters and
mercantilism and beggar-thy-neighbor
policies so openness to trade and to
private enterprise unless a certainly an
Enlightenment institution but of course
not democracy which another
enlightenment brainchild that was not
adopted so it's a it's kind of a hybrid
of I lighten Minh tand authoritarian
institutions how's this all look really
final question going forward one hundred
two hundred years since that's the frame
that talking about the Enlightenment
sort of raises you know here's this set
of ideas set of practices set of him
traditions that have been around for a
couple of centuries do they own the next
couple of centuries and if that's the
case are we basically just looking at
this trend line continuing or what what
what do you see in the longer timeframe
years oh what's the long now of this
whole question yes well I might pop out
by citing Phil tetlock who's spoken in
this series who found that even his
super forecasters the best of the best
predictors felt a chance five years out
so I I don't know I guess I guess the
best I could say is that it's possible
that it will continue I mean there are
huge challenges climate and being one of
them energy avoidance of the tail risks
like like nuclear war but but on the
other hand the process once set in
motion does barring these potential
catastrophes have the potential to
improve indefinitely even though if
it'll never bring us to utopia because
of human nature Crooked Timber of
humanity and all that stuff because
solutions generate new problems which
constantly have to be solved in their
turn but still barring the unlikely but
catastrophic events I think it's
possible with the promise will continue
for centuries when you leave you with a
research question for I don't know if
it's your next book but whatever that is
this is long-term thinking actually
useful or thing
or anything other than amusing yeah is
there you know if you look back in
alignment thinkers were very long-term
thinkers the founding fathers the us sir
war because they were actually sort of
creating a society and nation and
Cillian and the Constitution reflected
their ideas of what should be applicable
for generations so at least that set you
could probably say long-term thinking
was good for them but across the board
it would be interesting to tease out in
the way that you abused out that how the
Enlightenment values have played out and
it might play out is there any goddamn
value the long-term value yeah oh yes I
mean I'm but long-term thinking I think
we both agree this doesn't mean kind of
being a seer and prognosticating what
will happen but rather in game let us
just take a look sensibility for rather
than directly control the long term
exactly I mean just as yeah I think it's
actually essential to just clarify our
thinking even if it isn't making
confident prognostications but as a set
of what-if scenarios absolutely for the
same reason that I don't think you can
do history without thinking of
counterfactuals what would have happened
if just because the notion of cause and
effect is inherently tied to
counterfactuals
of the past and then and also of the
future so I think it's tremendously
valuable if it's not confused with
prophecy but it isn't prophecy it's it's
long-term thinking well we got Neil
Ferguson who does counter fractional
smoking other things is industry and
speaking in the fall so I'll ask him the
same question thank you for doing this
[Applause]
[Music]